hey guys we are in quarantine right now
we've been in quarantine for it seems
like ever now and so we wanted to bring
you into our journey a little bit and
show you some inside scoops of what
we've been doing Justin and Haley Bieber
are giving their fans an intimate look
at their life as a married couple in
quarantine for their news Facebook watch
series the Bieber's now obviously Justin
had given his believers a sneak peek at
his and Hayley's relationship earlier
this year in his youtube docu-series
seasons sometimes I still get nervous
with her in the room for some reason and
it's weird I know but like I know she
just makes me nervous cuz I love her so
much and I want her to like like my
stuff and it's about her too so i'm like
singing about her it's just like it's a
weird thing but it's awesome it's really
hard being the musical album but this
new weekly 12 episode event has the
Bieber's opening up their home in Canada
for an exclusive look at their
day-to-day lives through conversations
and activities with their famous friends
and family what are we doing next
we're to jump on the boat this is your
houseboat as you can see yep now in the
premiere episode Justin and Haley made
their way down to the lake where they
got candid about the highs and lows of
their relationship including their
breakup in 2016
how do you think you regained that trust
and the confidence in me because at the
time you know there was so much hurt and
there was so much pain what got you
through that was that your faith was a
I think that one thing that's really
important is that from the time where
you and I weren't you know like and it
was not on good terms you know I I was
you know I was on my own
essentially I didn't just like throw
myself into a relationship or throw
myself into something else
mm-hmm to try to like I did other things
to try to distract myself and to forget
and like would talk to people or hang
out with people but I didn't you know I
didn't search for like somebody to just
come take your place and he's like
another relationship
and try to fill a void in that way right
and their marriage in 2019 what's the
best thing what's the most rewarding
thing about being married would have you
found to be most rewarding well the most
rewarding thing about being married
definitely is just like just the
companionship I think that you get out
of it like the more that you work on it
you fight for it to be solid and you
fight for it to me it takes a lot of
work when you say like people yeah
obviously you have to work hard on our
relationship and I think that that pays
off in a way where you just become so
connected to each other yeah so
close and so just solid with each other
I mean obviously you remember threat mmm
so I think that's like the base payoff
is you have a best friend thing just do
everything with mm-hmm
what do you think has been the hardest
thing about being married the hardest
thing about me has been there's some
similarities that you said there's a lot
of things that I need to work on
forgiveness things jealousy things
insecurities that I needed to realize I
had until I chose to spend my life with
you I realized there's a lot of things
blind spots in my life that I didn't
realize that I had
that was really hard to work through
those things but I think you choose to
work through those things they actually
I feel like now that I've worked through
a lot of that stuff you and I are closer
than ever yeah I agree
honestly we can't get enough of these
two now after a jam-packed premiere fans
can tune in every Monday Wednesday and
Friday for new episodes of the Beavers
which will also include special Facebook
live episodes did you have a good time
will you remember that for the rest of
your life I love you babe
you